desperate for help bibi zahra says it
would be better to die than face this
humiliation she's been trying to find
shelter for nearly two months after her
husband was killed in kunduz
a similar story from northern and
central afghanistan repeated across the
sarai somali camp in kabul
many parks and open areas in the afghan
capital are now camps for displaced
people
jamal's daughter has been missing for
six days he breaks down explaining he's
looked for her in police stations
hospitals and morgues
people here surround us every step of
the way they're hoping someone has
solutions
even after the fighting is over this
woman has arrived yesterday from
northeastern kapisa she wants a tent a
spot for shelter
this water is for sanitation only but
drinking water is expensive and when
you're thirsty quality of water isn't a
priority the tank is filled every few
days for an estimated six thousand
people here if aid agencies or
philanthropists don't come people must
pitch in to buy the water
beside the washing and drinking is the
makeshift clinic
the open air single bed operation is run
by volunteers
in the last two months they have treated
cases ranging from pneumonia and
diarrhea to mental health issues
out of 46 pregnancies at the camp they
say 26 were miscarriages
decided not to leave afghanistan when
thousands of professionals fled after
the taliban take over
if the international community and the
world health organization is listening
to you right now what will you ask them
we don't have enough medicine we don't
have enough space we lack food and
drinking water i want to tell them that
at least 10 mothers gave birth here in
this camp i want the whole world to help
our people
aid workers estimate five and a half
million people across afghanistan have
been displaced a large population of
adults is going hungry so they can feed
their children the taliban have been in
battle for the last two decades but
their biggest challenge yet might be
fighting hunger
give them 2 000 breeds for 6 000 people
everyone used to get half a piece of
bread but today they don't have the
money to buy it
afghanistan faces multi-dimensional
crises people have been displaced by
conflict drought floods and natural
disasters and the taliban government
says it cannot help because western
powers do not recognize the current
government and have frozen assets
in the meantime aid agencies say they're
ready to work with the new
administration
part of our responsibility
is to not only address
these immediate life-saving
interventions
but is to try to work with the
interim government to try to find
solutions that work
ultimately for the afghan people
the interim minister for refugees told
al jazeera about plans to rehabilitate
people create jobs and help restart
their lives
but it will be a tricky interaction with
donors such as the un because khalil
rahman haqqani and others in this
government have been sanctioned by the
united nations
without that help people here fear their
problems will multiply especially as
winter approaches now that the fighting
is over in kunduz why are you not going
home
we eat plain bread at night and in the
morning what can i do
if someone helps me i'll go back if i
find enough money to pay the
transportation i'll go back even if i
don't have a house
and that involuntary return of the
displaced can only happen if and when
help arrives